Hey guys, I'm Eric Bidelman.
I'm a staff developer
relations engineer
working on Polymer at Google.
So in this video I'm going
to talk to you about how
you can use Polymer and
Web Components to interact
with some of Google's most
popular APIs and services
just by writing a
little bit of HTML.
The other day I was thinking,
how many APIs does Google have?
Do you now?
I actually did't.
I had to do my
research on this one.
So it's over 250 APIs.
Things like Google Maps and
Google Drive, Spreadsheets,
Calendar, Analytics.
You name it, Google's
probably got it.
And of course we all know
that creating complex web
applications requires
you to interact
with APIs and services.
So on the polymer
team we've been
thinking about
this a little bit.
How do you combine
Google's awesomeness
with the world of
Web Components?
We really want to make working
with Web Components as easy
as writing a little bit of HTML.
That's really the power
of Web Components.
And it turns out, they're
a great delivery vehicle
for wrapping existing content,
libraries, and services.
Think of it as a way to
declaratively provide
a declarative service area
for the API that exists.
This is really where
Polymer comes in.
For those that
don't know, Polymer
is a bleeding edge technology.
It's a library built
for the web that
allows you to create
web applications based
on Web Components.
But to me what
Polymer really does
is provide a thin layer
of opinionated layer
on top of the Web
Component APIs.
So we built in things like data
binding, property observation,
[? jester ?] support,
mobile support.
These are really important when
you're building applications.
We want to make it easier
for you to ramp up and use,
so we built that
into Polymer itself.
A popular API is something
like Google Maps.
It's very complex,
it's very rich.
So let's take a look at how
Web Components can actually
make your life easier
using that API.
This is Google
Maps' Hello World.
It's pretty simple, but there's
a little bit of boiler plate
code that you have to
write every time you want
to render just a
map to your page.
You have to know to style it
using a little bit of CSS.
You have to know that
there's a container
div that you need to create.
You have to load the library,
you have to remember that.
You have to work with
loading and callbacks
and write a little
bit of JavaScript.
The point is, there's
a lot of process
you have to go through to
get this thing kicking.
So let's see what we can
do with Web Components.
In the world of Web Components,
this is the Google Maps API.
It's a single tag you
declare on your page.
That's ridiculous,
ridiculously awesome.
You declare it and
you're off to the races.
And it does exactly
what you expect,
which is render a
map to your page.
It's simple, it's
declarative, it's intuitive.
I don't have to write
JavaScript code.
I don't have to know
about callbacks.
I don't have to read
API documentation.
You get my point.
You just use this
thing and it works.
But Google Maps is an
extremely complex API.
So instead of
writing JavaScript,
what we can do in
the world of Web
Components is expose attributes
on this element for people
to configure the different
properties and methods
that the API exposes.
So for instance, a really
common thing to do,
latitude and longitude.
Set the center of the map.
We can do that now using
the latitude and longitude
attributes.
We can also set the
zoom level of this map
just by setting the
zoom attribute to 15.
That's really awesome.
Again, it's all declarative
and super intuitive.
You can read this code
and know what's going on.
And adding markers
is just as easy.
It's just as declarative.
So we can drop in a bunch of
Google Map marker elements
inside of the Google
Map tag itself
and compose these
in different ways.
The fact that the market tag
is in the wrap is significant.
It knows to render that
marker to the page.
I'm also reusing other
parts of the platform here.
So you notice I didn't reinvent
the wheel for the title
attribute.
Or I didn't reinvent the wheel
for the drag and drop API.
I'm using the draggable
true attribute.
So again, I can use
parts of the web platform
that already exist.
I don't have to reinvent
that wheel every time
I start a new project.
That's cool.
The other thing I really
love about this element
is that it makes some of
the API complexity go away.
So one thing that's
really common
to do in the world
of Maps is center
your map inside of the
viewpoint of all the markers
contained inside of it.
Make sure they're available
to users at all times.
It's a little bit of
boilerplate code, a little bit
of JavaScript that
you have to know
how to write every
time you want to do it.
You add a new marker, you
want to update the map.
Instead, what we can do in
the world of Web Components
is again expose another
attribute, this Fit to Markets
attribute.
So as long as I have on my
marker tag, my map tag, boom,
the map just updates itself.
It knows to set the zoom
property accordingly.
That's Google Maps.
It's super declarative,
super easy to use.
But you could imagine a
ton of other use cases
here for all the APIs
Google has, whether it's
working which Charts or
Spreadsheets, Analytics.
Anything can be a Web Component.
We can provide a declarative
surface for people
to tap into that.
And that's exactly
what we've done.
So we've been experimenting
with this over on GitHub.
If you want to check
it out, Google Web
Components us the
GitHub organization.
We have a growing collection
of awesome components there,
things for Analytics and maps
you saw, Google Spreadsheets.
We also have base components
for doing more low-level things,
working with the
libraries that Google has,
doing OAuth2-- God knows
that is very complex.
So just like Maps, these
are super declarative, super
easy to use.
Check them out.
If anything is
missing, let us now.
We're really interested
in getting your feedback,
getting pool requests, and
adding new APIs and services
all the time.
So actually, let's use this.
Let's combine-- proof
in the pudding--
create an application that
uses Google Maps and Google
Spreadsheets.
We'll create a Polymer element
that wraps all that together,
and users can use
that element inside
of their own applications.
Oh yeah, I almost forgot.
We're not going to write
any JavaScript to do this.
We're just going to write
a little bit of HTML.
So if you're
curious, this data is
going to be coming from
a Google Spreadsheet.
This is what the data
actually looks like.
Essentially it's just a list of
business in Portland, Oregon.
There's a little
bit of metadata,
but the most
important thing here
is that we have the latitude
and longitude columns.
This is the data that's going
to render those marker objects.
So the first thing
we do, we've got
to bring this stuff
locally it our app.
We're going to use
Bio to install it.
We're going to Bio-install
the Google Map tag.
And then you see the example
here, which we've already seen,
so let's move on.
What you haven't seen is
the Google Sheets tag.
This is an element for working
with Google Spreadsheets.
We're also going to
Bio-install that, bring it
in locally to our application.
And the second example
here is how you actually
use this element.
So again, it's
super declarative.
I declared Google Sheets, and
boom, I'm off to the races.
It's got a Publish property,
which essentially means,
hey this data is being
published publicly.
Don't worry about doing
authentication just there.
GID corresponds to the
tab in the spreadsheet
that I want to interact
with, so GID 0, first tab.
And the last thing
that we're doing
is providing a spreadsheet key.
And you see the example here.
Where you actually get
the key is in the URL bar
when viewing the
spreadsheet in Google Docs.
So it's super easy to use.
And the last step, if
you're outside of Polymer
you just have to write a
little bit of JavaScript
to maybe listen for the
event that this element fires
and then it will
react accordingly.
So in this case, we
can print out the data
that the spreadsheet return.
But it's really that
easy, declare, go.
So that we have those
dependencies installed,
Google Maps and Sheets,
let's actually use them.
Let's create a
Polymer element that
wraps that
functionality together.
This is the entirety
of the application.
Let's walk through these pieces.
So the first thing, now that
we have the dependencies
installed, you want to listen
at the top of your file.
So this is using
HTML imports, which
is one of the Web
Component APIs.
We're going to list
Polymer as a dependency,
the Google Sheets
as a dependency,
and Google maps as
a dependency now
that they're in our application.
The second thing we're going to
do is create a Polymer element,
so using Polymer's declarative
sugaring to do this.
The name of the tag we're
going to create is map-sheets.
This is what somebody's actually
going to declare on their page
when they use our stuff.
The second thing you see here
is this no script attribute.
That's essentially just a
hint to Polymer to say hey,
I'm not going to
add any properties,
any methods to this.
It's just going to be
a little bit of markup
that we're essentially
repackaging for users.
So it's a pretty simple element.
Inside the Elements
template, you're
drop in that Google
Sheets component.
This is what's going to
talk to or spreadsheet.
You can see I've
got the key there,
I got that publish
attribute, and we're
data binding to
the rows attribute
that this thing has on it.
More on that in just a second.
Right below it we have
the Google Maps sheet.
This is your friendly tag
that we already know about.
Notice that we're using
that fit to markers
attribute that we
talked about before.
So again, any time I have
extra markers being rendered
in this map, it's
just going to know
to set the zoom level to
the appropriate level.
Lastly, what we're
doing is we're
using [? Plamers' ?]
declarative data
binding features to
declare the [INAUDIBLE]
over the row data returned
in the spreadsheet.
So again, I'm not writing
any JavaScript code
to wire this stuff up.
I'm literally just
declaring a template,
looking over the data, and
stamping out Google Map marker
children.
And of course, we're data
binding that latitude
and longitude property
to the particular cell
that we're interested in.
So again, it's all
super declarative,
and the surface area is
just using HTML attributes.
So that's the entirety
of the application.
If somebody wants
to use this, it's
just a matter of
bringing in platform JS.
These are the
polyfills that actually
allow you to use the
stuff in browsers
that don't support
the native APIs.
Check.
You want to declare the Google
Maps sheet as an HTML import.
That's going to bring in
the element we just created.
Check.
The last thing you
want to do is just
declare the Map sheets
tag on your page.
And of course, what people
get is this beautiful map,
marker data, all powered
by Google Spreadsheets.
We didn't write
any code to do it.
We used Polymer Web Components.
That's the bee's knees.
So if you want to see a live
demo of this, go check it out.
It's at
googlewebcomponents.github.io.
We have this demo,
as well as a ton
of other demos for all the
other components we've created.
So that's a small taste,
just a small, small taste
of what Polymer and
Web Components can do.
I really think
Web Components are
going to lock a fundamentally
new way to program for the web.
You've already seen,
it's productive,
it's declarative, its reusable.
And you can vastly
reduce the amount of code
you write as a
front end developer.
That's really, really awesome.
So if you want to know more
about creating applications
using Polymer, do check
out Rob Dodson's video
and Addy Osmani's video.
These are some stellar guys
with some really, really great
content.
Check us out at
polymer-project.org.
This is our website, powered
by Polymer, of course.
And follow us on
Twitter @polymer.
You can also feel free to hit me
up at any time, ask questions.
I'm always on Twitter.
I'm on Google Plus.
Oh yeah, one last thing.
Go componentize the web, guys.
Thanks for watching.